imagine life in 12,000 BC there are no  society no protection no guarantee  just small bands of nomads wandering the  woods of Eurasia trying to survive in a  hostile world these people lived in very  fredita rich environments lots of  animals who regarded humans as prey fire  was at the Talon it protected you  against predators  imagine a life so fragile so fraught  with uncertainty only fire offers the  chance at survival moment to month  this is the moment in time when life  almost safety depends on this trick take  control of the natural world and create  a weapon to fight back  fire gave us a chance at a future  Oh  [Music]  I